Oh distracted worried hey Elsa we know
that you have a lot going on in frozen
to an unknown voice is calling your name
and it wants you to go north you're
going to travel into the great unknown
to discover more about yourself and save
arendelle if anyone can save arendelle
it's you but what comes next some fans
still think you need a love interest or
will you decide that being queen isn't
for you we think there are definitely
enough storylines for a third movie and
I know what that means
frozen fans are already excited about
the prospect of a frozen three movie
Disney is far from confirming the third
film but that doesn't mean it's off the
table stay tuned as we reveal why frozen
three needs to happen love stories one
of the biggest reasons fans want frozen
3 - Hoffman has everything to do with
the love stories we love seeing Anna and
Kristoff slowly fall for each other in
the first film like it they are just
perfect for each other in frozen - they
are still together
we know that Kristoff wants to propose
to Anna but he keeps trying to find the
right time from what we've heard about
the new movie he keeps getting
interrupted when he tries to propose
poor Kristoff frozen 3 would be a great
opportunity to explore their romance
imagine if something happens bother
planning their wedding
maybe Hans comes back into the picture
after all he was technically engaged to
Anna will you marry me yes that could be
some serious drama or maybe something
happens to Kristoff before the wedding
and Anna and Elsa have to save him
there is definitely no shortage of
storylines for a movie all about
Kristoff and Anna getting married there
are also plenty of fans who think Elsa
needs a love interest
you probably remember the give Elsa a
girlfriend campaign it started before
frozen 2 was even announced many fans
were disappointed to learn that Elsa
will not be falling in love in the
second movie fine
who is calling to you they may have
answers but there is always the
possibility of a three cold in fact a
new site called we got this covered
reported that Elsa is getting the
girlfriend in frozen three but we aren't
sure who their super secret source is
Disney execs have said that there are
currently no plans for a third movie
they will have to wait and see how
successful frozen 2 is mattress pad and
at this point they don't even have a
plot for the third installment we
guessed people who want an Elsa love
story will have to keep hoping Elsa
stays behind Elsa's never really felt
like she fit in because of her magic and
her powers just keep getting stronger in
frozen - she says and from what the
trailers say it seems that she'll get
all her answers about her magic in the
enchanted forest no one has been allowed
in or out of the forest for decades
who are you but her magic allows her end
what if Elsa finally finds where she
belongs we could totally see her
choosing to stay behind at the end of
frozen - she never wanted to become
Queen at her young age do you have to go
you will be fine Elsa but she lost her
parents she might not want to be the
queen of arendelle if she stays in a
place of magic she might tell Anna to
take over the throne and that would
definitely open up a possibility for a
third movie on a doesn't want to rule
either and she wants to stay with her
sister we do this together okay I
promise frozen three could be about Elsa
needing to return to arendelle to save
her sister from some threat or maybe she
only wanted to stay away to find herself
and get better at magic
a third movie could be about her journey
home all about Anna the frozen movies
maybe about sisterly love but they're
more geared towards else's journey the
first movie was about Elsa learning to
accept her powers and Anna trying to
convince her to come home You Belong
down in arendelle
so do you the second movie is about Elsa
learning more about her powers and
saving arendelle Anna is there because
she supports her sister plenty of fans
think frozen three should be mostly
about Anna there have been lots of
theories that Anna might have powers of
her own she might be the fire queen -
Elsa's ice cream frozen three could
definitely explore ah no learning to
harness her
own magic but maybe on a doesn't have
powers she could go on her own adventure
perhaps she tries to find out what
happened to their parents or maybe Hans
comes back and causes all sorts of
problems for her it could be that Elsa
needs to save Anna this time around and
we would love to see Kristoff be a huge
hero either way a movie about Anna would
be totally awesome we will have to wait
and see how frozen 2 ends but we know
there is still so much does Nika do with
Elsa and Anna frozen 3 would make so
many fans happy why do you think there
should be a third frozen movie don't be
shy tell us your theories in the
comments thanks for tuning in be sure to
like this video and subscribe to the
things for more great content we'll
catch you next time